hey everybody welcome back to LED live
today we're gonna talk about the power
behind every Christian the power of
prayer
are you experiencing this power in your
life find out on this episode of LED
live so I love this topic because this
is basically the foundation of every
Christian I mean literally this is
exciting because there are things that
we cannot accomplish on our humans level
and every time I hear of amazing
testimonies amazing stories you know Jim
you guys you come up a lot in
conversation this man travels the world
we're very pleased to have you on our
show and this is a person that operates
solely on the power of prayer by the
grace of God and I'm excited to hear
some of these testimonies today he comes
to us from the Philippines and this man
is a prayer warrior right here so tell
us a little bit about your background oh
I guess as if you have mentioned I'm
from the Philippines I was a
photographer before I was a wedding
photographer and they always tell people
always a photographer never the groom
yes and I've been traveling around a
little bit with Jim and and let me tell
you this guy takes phenomenal
photographs I do have some pretty
amazing photographs you can literally
hand the same technology to two people
and it's interesting how one person can
just excel in that area oh praise God
but you did this you did this for a
profession yes you did this for a
profession thinking that I that I'm
doing what I have been dreaming about
thinking that this is one thing that I
want to do I want to help the ministry I
want to help the church and I want to
become rich and this is gonna be like my
my life and then just to find out it's
frustrating like it's just like climbing
on top of a mountain and expecting to
see a beautiful view and when you are
there on top of them
this is it yeah I don't want to stay
here yeah so and the Lord somehow
changed my life around I think that's
how everybody feels you know I rep
shoulders with enough people who in
quote-unquote made it somewhat
successful in in the Hollywood setting
and when you get there it's like really
this is this is what everybody's like
trying to achieve and and it's really
not all cracked up to be
you know success in life as we see
success in a worldly sense is not always
like fulfilling hmm you know I mean yes
and so when you really kind of dedicate
your life to God it's it's it can really
like change the course everything so how
did you get away from that and into this
ministry oh it's a it's funny because
before being a photographer I was
already thinking that I want to be a
missionary because there was this
conference that I have attended and and
the speaker said you have to be a
missionary or you're nothing so it's a
proud kid I say I don't want to be
nothing I even convinced my to my
friends and hey do you want to be
nothing and he had to be missionaries
and that was like I was like 11 years
before I officially became a missionary
and that time I was so excited because I
was thinking I can do this I'm I'm gonna
be a blessing of the Lord the Lord is so
so blessed to have me on his no so the
Lord has to bring me to the point of
obscene all my defects seeing that
without him I can do nothing that's why
I love that verse in John 15 verse 5 the
bottom part for without me can do
nothing realizing that and when that
when that one was made reality in my
life that's when prayer becomes a
reality - that's an interesting point
about if you're not a missionary you're
nothing if we take our identity and our
instruction from Christ he tells us to
go out into all the world preaching the
gospel and that doesn't mean you have to
be a full everyone needs to be a
full-time missionary but in whatever is
fair you find yourself in you should be
finding every opportunity to share the
love of Christ
now that's that's interesting because
you know when we started this you you
you gave us a little bit of a a tagline
that you would consider to be part of
your ministry talk a little bit about
this what does this mean
yes so that's a beautiful tagline
although while I thought that it's it's
just it's just those words that that
buff senior in front of you when when
you hear those words it's powerful but
then I realized that this is the life
that God wants us to live all of us not
just for missionaries that he wants us
to to abide with him to rely fully upon
him as he has said without me can do
nothing so the only way to survive is to
cling on to divine for without him I can
do nothing and when people ask me so Jen
how do you how do you do this and for
audiences just to let them know that I
have been living life by faith for by
the grace of God for the past nine years
plus and no no regular income I don't do
solicitation I don't do the nation
campaign I would I just rely on the Lord
for everything in spite the life of
George Muller and I and remember this
that verse it says faith cometh by
hearing and hearing by the Word of God
so I heard the testimony and somehow I
ask myself is that really real does God
really do that
even now the Lord challenged me right
and by absolutely relying upon him I'm
seeing like miracles happen day after
day and and his promises are being
fulfilled and when you don't rely on
anything except his word this becomes a
reality right right yeah you know and
and what's funny too is like in George
wheelers case I mean correct me if I was
wrong but he started out sort of a rough
path yes right I mean he had a very
checkered upbringing
Thievery you name it he was not a very
good person and when he got his heart
won by God I mean that total absolute
reliance on God for everything I
remember reading stories about him
having orphanages and literally they had
no food I mean tons of kids no food and
they were just like you know what God's
gonna provide and I was setting trucks
would show up outside of the building
and be like hey we baked too much bread
and we thought you guys could use some I
mean that mean those kind of stories
have been non-stop time and time again
so yeah so so have you had anything like
this this happened oh so can you share
can you share what are the stories of us
one of the things that they're that I
was really thinking about like so how is
this gonna be possible if you're calling
me to be a missionary and and the Lord
has really tugging in my heart to be a
missionary outside of the Philippines
there are some situation back home that
it really calls me to be outside in the
Philippines and thinking how is this
gonna be possible if I don't have what's
this salary or a permanent source of
income and you know what we were
traveling to India during the time that
was my first trip outside of the
Philippines as a missionary and the Lord
used its my stingiest relative and the
person asked me cell hey I heard that
you're going to to India and I said yes
how much money do you have
I had a 10 bucks how are you gonna
survive I totally the Lord will provide
and then he says ah okay go to the
nearest money transfer I'm sending you
hundred bucks
Wow you know what's amazing I went to
India and back and 100 bucks was still
in town and after that Scott I said I
like this kind of life I mean it's
really amazing like how many countries
do you travel into like a year like how
many different locations did you go last
year help County I mean are we talking
like you're
every weekend you're almost somewhere
else Oh like almost every week I fly to
a different state okay so I basically
live in the airplane or the airport I
have not fully emptied my my suitcase
for the past like five six years
oh so you're telling me that you don't
ask for money no you don't have a salary
no but yet you fly around you have all
these locations that you go to this is
amazing
oh we serve an amazing guy we said
authorial gut and this is one thing I
think that that we discount God most of
the time because we look at God and we
think that he is he has a capacity like
us as well
like financial capacity or physical
capacity but no he's God he spoke and
all this world came into existence
I mean think of think of this world we
have royalty and then we have people who
have like generational wealth they don't
have to worry about Sally or we're you
know if they want to travel they can
just get on a plane and go we have a
heavenly father they have that has more
riches than all of those families
combined so it should be no surprise
that you're living this lifestyle and
you're able to put your faith in him
your trust in him and he's taking care
of every single need it's powerful he's
God and that's so that's how true candy
because look at this when those powerful
people when they make things happen what
what do they do
they call they call their their contacts
hey do this hey do that God doesn't need
to call anything or anyone and when he
created this world he didn't need
assistance he didn't even need a
material yeah he just spoke and all this
world came into existence so it means to
say that that this is powerful so if we
believe the word the way the way God
created this world our lives would would
have power in it right that's true
sometimes we call of our earthly
contacts and forget the most empowered
one I love that idea that you know this
is God's words like this is his actual
physical words that he spoke to us and
when God spoke something in the the
beginning of the world it came into
existence immediate
right those words created this immediate
response to the physical universe and
you know you think of the stories when
Jesus was in the boat with the disciples
and there's a storm all around right and
he gets up but he says peace be still I
mean it didn't take you know 15 minutes
or or a half-hour for the wind to die
down the Bible actually uses the word
immediately yes the second that he spoke
those words immediately there was an
action that happened right now and so
God God speaks words to us that we can
stand on and we say he said it so it's
gonna happen yeah and when he says he's
gonna take care of you I mean you're
walking proof of that mmm but it takes
that ultimate reliance that that that
just you know like you've got to
literally say okay god it's in your
hands you figure it out and you've been
doing this for five years and by the way
I just want to make it clear I'm not
going around having party and no it's
when you're doing things for the glory
of God for the glory of God and that's
that's one thing most of the time
because before I was thinking about
prayer as getting or twisting the arm of
God for the things that I would want to
have in my life and that doesn't work
and now I know that it should be in
accordance to his will it should be in
accordance to what the Lord desires and
later on I find out that living this
life his will fulfills my desire
fulfills my joy and all the while I
thought that following his will I would
negate myself from from having my own
beautiful experience but then I realized
that God's desire for me is way higher
than mine this is a good this is a good
point I was just thinking about that as
you're talking about God is not a genie
you know you don't come and rub the lamp
and you get three wishes and then you
get whatever you want
those are selfish motives the mile tells
us in James chapter 4 verse 3 it says
you ask and do not receive because you
ask amiss that you may spend it on your
own pleasures right so we have we have
by our sinful nature we have these
carnal hearts and we can think of all
these things that we want and desire and
would like to have but in the end
usually we're just gonna spend that on
ourselves and on other people but if you
put yourself in God's hands you know
under his will and asked Lord what do
you want like Jesus you know Jesus was
seeking you know he said I seek not my
will but the will of him who sent me and
when he did that Jesus did amazing
things right and God can do amazing
things through us when we put ourselves
in the same position yeah I have a
question if you guys were to define
prayer how would you define it that's a
very good question
hmm and that's that's one thing I'd like
to share as well about what brother
Keith shared a while ago because all the
while I thought as I shared that
although I thought it's rubbing the land
the right way so that you'll get what
you want it's actually a different a
different understanding right now as I
get involved in the prayer ministry
prayer is not just getting what you want
is getting to know his will because what
his will is is the best for us because
come to think of it do we really know
what we want do we really know what we
need we think we do we think we do it's
just like we are we are kids in on a
table not wanting to eat our breakfast
because you want chocolate and if you
receive all the things that you desire
it will not be so good for you and this
is one thing as well that you said it's
not it's not the selfish things that
that we would ask and and his will
protects us from our selfishness and our
selfishness brings us depression our
selfishness brings us unhappiness I
remember that time because I'm a selfish
man and during the time that I would
want to get what I want and I got it it
did not bring me happiness did not bring
me fulfillment but this time I was
seeing like wow this is what the law
desires for all these people and that's
why I'm so excited to share this I I
cannot keep it to myself and I've been
I've been traveling and I'm seeing
people who have who have reached the
point that I desire to reach going to
one country
I saw this man he picked me up he and
his brand-new Mercedes Benz right at his
house he has six luxury cars arrived at
his out man I I will I will get lost in
his house I had I had in my room was
this indoor swimming pool and then and
then we talked because he is in a stock
market the wife is also a business woman
three four storey house so you were in
disappear there like that is so big on a
little guy and then one night we were
sitting down and he asked me Jen why are
you so happy and then I was not prepared
to answer that question better keep and
I was just like it was like my first
year being a missionary and I answer it
wrongly I said no Jim like literally I
think every time I've ever seen you
you're smiling I mean the world could be
burning around and he's is like how are
you you Seibert yes joy the real joy in
your heart give you and I want always to
correct people and when they when they
see when they say that because they
think that it's about personality it's
not right without God gem would be a
grumpy Jen right without God and I tell
you if I do not spend my time with God
in a morning a significant amount of
time I will not have joy I will not have
peace but knowing that you are that you
are handled by a God who holds the world
who could say his promises and fulfill
it
what's there to worry about right what's
there to to be crazy about right now
right you know it takes a lot of
pressure off of you when you really have
that connectiveness and and you're
allowing God to direct your life I mean
life throws you curveballs all the time
there's things you can't control
there's things that like you know that
you go through bumps in the road no
doubt your life has had bumps in the
road
right this is not all bliss smiley happy
faces right
hearts puffy everywhere no there's very
real things that the devil is constantly
trying to discourage you and kick you
off kilter or whatever but when you have
that that reliance on God then it's like
well you're in control God so no matter
what the outcome is you desired this and
I think that's how Paul and you know the
other apostles that were thrown into
prison we're little able to smile and
able to sing songs right singing songs
because they realized hey look we're
here in jail yes this is a terrible
situation my arms hurt
but God there's some reason why you
wanted me here I think about how many
people have had encouragement through
the ages because of those stories
amen so you know Paul couldn't see down
the line but if he could he'd say wow
God you had this all worked out so we we
had a question on the table I think it's
important for our viewers to hear out
and that is how would you define prayer
so let you take this first stab at it
Jim so I think as I've said a while ago
prayer is getting to know his will when
even even when you look at the the
gesture of prayer you don't pray like
this
mmm you don't pray like this mm-hmm
you person trait yourself mm-hmm to the
ground you bow you submit mmm prayer is
about submission president about a
command prayer is not about a demand
prayers about submission and this is one
thing because of our selfish nature it's
somehow obliterates the whole concept
about prayer and by submitting to him
he's gonna lead because he says in psalm
32 verse 8 I will instruct you and teach
you in the way that you should go I will
guide you with mine I and most of the
time we cannot be guided we could not be
led we could not be instructed because
we think we know what we want we think
we know where we're going and what we're
doing but in reality we're not we don't
even know what's gonna happen next week
and five minutes from now I'll always
tell people do you even know I'm gonna
do this no holy God knows there is a
path that seems right into a man
at the end leads to destruction you know
prayer is recognizing our insufficiency
hmm you know and coming to God and
humility and realizing I'm nothing mmm
I can do nothing yes I have nothing and
when you come to God and that's that's
what prayer does it allows us to come to
God it's connecting us to the source of
all wisdom and power and truth and it
brings us to God and then like you said
at that point then we submit and we say
what do you want Lord what's your will
and it's also a conversation we're
coming to God but it's also time for him
to come to us for us to take some time
and hear what he has to say in his word
and before you were talking about you
know not really knowing what's best for
us and what we need well we learned that
through the Bible so it's not for us to
just pray and then you know run we
should hear what God has to say and I
kind of left and you were talking before
about not praying like this but it's
funny we could be physically prostrate
and praying to God but mentally
we're just listing our demands and then
moving on shop English so humility is
not just how you how you're physically
praying like how you present yourself
but also mentally what you're thinking
in your heart having children really
changed my my way that I pray because
you know children always come to you I
want pancakes I want them now and you
know I want all these fixings on it and
why aren't you getting this fast enough
right that's like literally well but
kids do to you right and and you hear
about all day long there's just little
requests you know do this dad do this
dad do this dad and they're liking
seeking pleasure from their parents but
it's like in a in a selfish manner most
of the time and so you know it really
made me kind of reflect on that and say
is that how we treat God it is literally
every prayer that I pray only asking for
things help me with this heal this do
this you know what I mean like a genie
thing you guys brought up earlier right
are you just are you just connecting
yourself to God because he's the
ultimate source of power and I just I
just really want him to work some things
out in my life right I love the idea
that you guys brought up it's really
getting to know the will of God now
there's there's different
aspects of Prayer talk about those kind
of like like different components
because in your prayer ministry you know
you have like four basically different
groups of prayers that you kind of focus
on talk a little bit about that yeah the
praise and thanksgiving Oh
basically the praise first okay and then
the confession okay is that what you're
yes yes and supplication yes and then
Thanksgiving okay so why why why do you
start with praise
we start with praise because look at
this most of the time when we were
praying and and most of the people that
I that I encounter in before they saying
Jen I prayed but nothing happened
because most of the time we come to the
Lord with our with our shopping list
with our demand list or laundry list so
we we gave that to him and and all that
we could see is the mountain in front of
us we forget the character the power of
the God we serve and by praising him it
reminds us about powerful our God is you
know amazing our God is hmm so that's
that's the reason why we should start
out with praise the praise is not for
God God does not need our praise to feel
like oh I'm big and then the moment you
praise God the moment you realize how
powerful how faithful he is it brings
you to the point what you really should
be as dust and that's so and that just
leads you to the point that I should
confess not that oh I have I have been
selfish and that brings you to the point
of really asking at Lord please search
my heart so that's a confession part
reveal to me my motives and and it says
in Daniel if there's an equity in my
heart we will not hear my prayer and and
when you go through that humbling part
then the Lord could easily direct you
and even direct your prayer because the
Lord desires that he directs us on what
to us we don't even we don't even know
what to ask for
yes and and when we go to the asking
it's now him taking over that lead and
all you have to do in the end is thank
him yeah
mm you know it's interesting the the
topic of praise you know why do we
praise God what is the purpose of that
you know he's not narcissistic now he
needs us to like tell him that right and
you know I've also self reflected on
that as well in my personal human
relationships you know do we do we talk
about the things that we enjoy about our
spouses or people around us our
co-workers you don't I mean it's so easy
to be like this person rubs me wrong and
I don't like this but but simply when
you change those words and you go you
know what there's something I can find
that I like in everyone and when you
begin to like view that with just people
it changes the way that you interact
with those people so when you do that
with God oh it changes the way that you
you you approach him with this odd
presents because you're verbalizing that
praise yeah and there's this one story
not my story but the one story that I
always bring bring up when it comes to
the Thanksgiving or praise there was
this author he was writing something in
an in a cafe in Brazil and there's this
orphans they call them Street rats poor
kids and this this guy this this little
guy was so hungry looking through the
window through this glass and he saw
that there's like bread and this boy is
almost drooling and this author was so
moved by what he saw he bought a whole
loaf of bread loaf of bread and then
brought it to the boy and the boy just
like grabbed the loaf and then run maybe
he'll change his mind this is my
opportunity and then the author said a
grateful street rat so he went back to
his reading it's his book or his
newspaper and then a five minutes later
he felt a tug in his shirt and then that
was this the boy that took the bread
came back and he said a brigade Oh No
thank you
wait obrigado thank you very much and
the boy kept repeating it obrigado and
the guy said for that time I want to buy
the whole bakery for him
and that's that's us we are not even so
expressive of what the Lord has done to
us Fame and look back on what the Lord
has done in your life there's countless
moments and I guess that's one thing
that's a reason why because of the
sadness of this world is because we have
been ungrateful Wow Jay it's very truth
and then you know what and that's that's
for me as well kandi might my survival
because every time I face something I
face something that's that's difficult
it's a trial it's an obstacle the Lord
will always when I pray to him the Lord
will always remind me look back on what
have I done in the past have I failed
you mmm and then I begin thanking God
and it just changed the mood and and I
and it's a transformation from being
like despondent to being this joyful
mm-hmm
there any for our viewers of any
resources yuria men like reading
resources on how they can learn more
about this I guess prayer process if you
will home so that they can maybe
understand a little more deeply these
these things that we're talking about
there any anything you recommend I'll
recommend the book of my good friend
melody Mason they are daring to ask for
more and was this there's also resources
and revival and Reformation that orj
click the word resource and there's this
booklet it's called praying for rain and
it explains deeper what the like you've
got brought a while ago the four aspects
of prayer and it also teaches you how to
lead out and and to be an influence to
other people who needs prayer because
prayer ministry I although while I
thought this is just for the women yeah
this is just for the old people right
like those people who could not function
well so all they have to do is stay and
pray somewhere and then sleep and then
and I realized no this is the most
exciting ministry this is the most
exciting life and we thought that we are
doing great things already but I tell
you when you do things with God and by
God
that's the real adventure that's right
so listening to what you were saying
about praise it seems like actually all
fought or all four elements it seems
like you got that from the principles
Jesus gives in the Lord's Prayer and he
starts off you know our Father which out
in which are in heaven hallowed be thy
name
you know that kingdom come Thy will be
done on earth as it is in heaven
and it seems like Jesus is just
addressing God for who he is and giving
praise and thanks but I have a question
about that addressing God for who he is
because I'm when you teach a little
child how to pray you know you teach
that Jesus is their friend and they
should be always open and willing to
talk to him so I've heard prayers that
start or start off dare daddy
mmm but dear friend or even like hey
what's up bro I'm curious as to because
yes Jesus is our friend but he's also
our King he's our Lord so is it
important to address him as such in our
prayers for me it is but the Lord takes
us where we are and and the more you get
to know him the more you'll see this
he's not just a bro all right he is he
is majesty his glory his all-powerful
but we start somewhere and this is one
thing amazing about our God even the
witness when you say a bro we did that
that Satya
this is one attribute of our God it is
so awesome his patience towards us his
grace towards us and the more you get to
know him the more you fall in love with
him and the more you get to know this
God in the times that you spend time
with him on your knees the more you just
be amazed that he's not that God that
that a lot of people are portraying that
he is and and this is one thing that
I've encountered as well with people who
who has questions regarding God they're
saying so Jen if God is this why why God
is doing this why God is doing that and
I said you got the wrong idea and I said
so and they asked me so where where can
I find God because the moment I read in
the Internet is this this and that has a
brother if you want to know somebody do
you go to their enemies interesting you
have to go and meet the person first and
this is where you meet him and you know
like even just simply if you don't know
how to read this
you don't even I mean this this this
this is probably intimidating for
somebody then that that just picks it up
for the first time I mean I've heard as
many wonderful stories and testimonies
and people picking it up and just diving
into it yeah but just simply going got
it I didn't even know how to talk to you
mmm like you know teach sweet and that
spirit that that you approach God and
just like have that teachable open heart
he will literally you know direct you
and and then you will find yourself
doing things that you know you maybe
otherwise wouldn't have thought you
would have done I often wonder what
would I do if I stood in the presence of
God like there's a few examples of
people in the mind I've stood before God
and you they just read immediately on
their face yes and like wouldn't even
look at him and it's like you know what
oh is me I am undone because I am a
person of unclean lips and I'm like wow
I'm a lot more sinful than what I read
of that person in the Bible but I'm also
a very visual person I mean like like
I'm gonna see this majesty of this God
you know but but because of the nature
of the situation would I just what I
would I not do that and what I've
literally bow out of reverence I often
wonder that yeah so why don't you think
we see more demonstrations of God
presenting himself in all his glory or
even healing through prayer why don't
you think we see that in this day and
age or in this region of the world I
should say mm-hmm
that's a good question and it's this
thing as well that I now I've been
experiencing like near
laughter America like God's provision
here and there and then I asked myself
one time Lord why aren't these things
why weren't these things happening to me
before me and the Lord just simply
opened my eyes and helped me to see that
because it's because you have not relied
on me before the way you're relying on
me now
very simple like for example I'll tell
you about my visa interview and that's
that's usually that the thing that I
share with people when I when I applied
when I was asked to go and apply for a
visa in the u.s. I told my friends you
know it's not possible and they said
generally been living by faith why not
move by faith and said okay I didn't
have any faith that the Lord will
provide but fast forward now I was I was
there at a visa what do you call this
immigration I'm a great senior u.s.
embassy so I was there standing and my
heart was was pumping so bad and I was
about to pass out thinking this is not a
good picture denied so I said Lord what
should I do
and the Lord convicted me to pray so I
went and look around there's no place to
pray the Lord gave me the idea the
bathroom
praise God a u.s. embassy bathroom is
clean when they're closed the cubicle
knelt down and prayed as I've never
prayed before and this is one thing
amazing about our God he said seek me
and you will what when you find me when
you seek me with all of your heart and
the Lord gave me that peace in a
bathroom stall and when I came out when
I came out of that stall I was I had at
peace I never had before and now the
interview came and the lady and and the
guy asked me I said so mister cast or
how much is your monthly income that's
the first question
zero so the Lord convicted me the other
I sorry sir but I don't have a monthly
income and so how do you live I live by
faith sir Wow
so good for you you say well I did not
say you alright he was mad because all
the while he thought that I was joking
around so I he told me I live by faith
too but tell me how do you live how do
you buy your food how do you bury
clothes I told him the Lord provides her
Wow so he opened my passport and he saw
my passport was half way stand like 20
pages stamp and he said so if you're not
paid for your work how come you travel
so much and I told him sir
God is faithful and the Lord provides
all those things I'm I've worked as a
missionary I'm the prayer ministry so I
prayed the Lord in the Lord answers
those prayers how about your hotel how
about your food how do you survive
outside with the Philippines and I told
him sir God is faithful that I live in
the homes and those people who invites
me in and they feed me which is true and
then he said so
how about emergencies do you encounter
emergencies and said yes sir emergencies
are unavoidable and how are you gonna
pay for emergencies and I said the Lord
is faithful sir that the Lord provides
the right amount of money for the right
amount of emergency and now it tells me
so you tell me that you don't receive
that you receive money for emergencies
and I said yes sir God is faithful and
then he yelled at me oh wow then you
just told me a while ago that you don't
receive any amount of money for your
work now you tell me that you receive
money for emergencies you're lying and I
was I was caught in in a difficult
situation and I know for a fact that I
would have passed out remember my
condition before I was having panic
attack and God is so good that when you
come to him and you pray the Lord just
provides everything and God gave me the
answer before he's even done asking the
question and the answer was sir a while
ago you're you're asking for him for a
regular monthly income but emergencies
are not regular the moment that came out
of my mouth I know it was not my idea
and I was just having this this
expression at the back of my head like
and this is one things God that I
realized that when God does things in
your life you just be an audience in oh
you cannot deny that it is him who's
done that for you right and then a few
more seconds he I told him sir
a while ago a while ago I told you that
I I don't have income I don't have a
bank account and I was not lying I've
been living by faith for the past two
years during a time a year and a half
and he told me so how should I feel in
this question monthly income I don't
know
okay monthly income he typed in not
applicable and then he told me
congratulations visas approved
praise God and he gave me 10-year
multiple-entry so the Lord wanted to be
sure that I will not think that it is
just a coincidence he wants his his
fingerprint in that he wants his
signature in that he wants me to know it
is only by my grace by my faithfulness
that you've got this we are called to
just be that willing open heart and he
has these details worked out and
sometimes he puts you in uncomfortable
situations but look at what that does to
your faith yes you don't I mean it's
like we we we get to test God and see
like wow he is faithful he is powerful
you know I mean I think I what I'm
listening to you talk I'm thinking of
the story of the heavenly man brother
really
hey have you met this guy no his stories
are just fascinating I mean the same
sort of thing getting to the immigration
and they're just like you know like this
pictures not even you know and he's just
like I'm gonna let you go just prove
that we're gonna come find you
Jim at this point it's been really good
stories you pray things happen mm-hmm
but it doesn't always work that way yes
and for our viewers mm-hmm they might
start praying about a difficult
situation in their in their life maybe
they want to be free from some addiction
maybe it's a drug addiction or some kind
of media addiction or a romantic
addiction or whatever and they start
praying and then either something's not
happening or an obstacle gets in the way
big obstacle yes have you ever had a big
obstacle oh yes what do you do when you
get to that big obstacle oh I didn't
know what to do at first that obstacle
was what's a trigger for I didn't even
know that I had depression during the
time but who would think Jenna's
depressed
I was trying to hide it mmm and and that
when I look back right now I would not
change anything except my reaction I
should have humbled myself because I was
trying to to prove that I was right no
this I don't deserve this Lord and
that's why God says in 2nd chronicles 7
verse 14 if my people which are called
by my name shall humble themselves
humility is really where it all begins
because most of the time we are not
happy of the outcome because it's not
the outcome that we want to happen but
we don't know that God God puts a
stumbling block God God put a detour
because he wants you to go somewhere
else and when I look back right now
based on what I have experienced because
of that obstacle is the reason why I'm
here right now is the reason why I'm not
there in the Philippines and I'm I'm
experiencing what I should not have
experienced before
and there's a beautiful quote from from
from what I've read it says the time
will come that it will be revealed to us
the seemingly disappointed hopes and
unanswered prayers
the things that have annoyed us would
have been a greatest blessing mmm which
is so true and again prayer is not just
about getting something
it's getting to know that we love God
and I'd like to I'd like to to bank on
that what what you have said like what
happens when when your prayer is not
answered because most of the time we are
not even aware that there is something
that we're hanging on to that stops us
from receiving the answer from receiving
the blessing and this is one thing that
I'd like to commend this ministry for
because I was I was in that in that
addiction part I was not addicted to do
anything that's really really crazy or
anything I wasn't addicted to media I
was addicted to to movies like this is
how I got to know this brother mm-hmm
and not personally but through the the
ministry that you're doing the sermon
that I I heard one time and it really
pricked my heart I had 1500 DVD
collection my room was filled with it
[Laughter]
there's no copyright it's so I like
binge every single day it's at least
eight hours per day Oh at least eight
hours I could not function without
passing myself in a movie and when the
series came out here and in the u.s. you
sell series buy my DVDs buy CDs ours one
DVD all series so you watch it like 18
hours and I could not go to sleep until
I you know how how this cliffhangers and
then that's that's the kind of life I
lived so when that was this decision it
needs to get done like there was the
speaker in a youth conference which I
had organized
I was the youth leader and I had that
that that little struggle in my life and
I said okay lord I give it to you and I
came forwarding that appeal and I was
weeping I was crying thinking what's
life
gonna be after DVDs and I did not know
that life just began yeah and this this
ministry is a huge was this a huge help
for me because after leaving that I
didn't know where to start and then this
materials came out and Scott and and
Tommy spoke about about their the
release from from Hollywood how all
these things somehow blocks them from
seeing the real joy in their lives and
me and my friends watch that and and it
somehow gave us like wow there's more
joy outside of Hollywood then than we
think we have and we begin to be
addicted with this so and this is one
amazing thing that when those things are
cleared out
you begin to see the beauty of the word
you begin to see the beauty of the
beautiful promises that God has given
you and come to think of it what I was
hooked on before was all eyes was all
like conceptualized by the human mind
but this one is real I was watching I
was reading the story of Jonathan that
story Jonathan in his armor-bearer and
seeing when they fought the Philistines
just imagine how many how many chariots
there how many how many horsemen thirty
thousand six thousand and then and in
footmen like the sand of the seashore
there's only two men who fought with
them and it says there I was reading
this this commentary they were being
spear they were being shot like with an
arrow I did not reach him you know why
it says that the angel of the Lord
shielded them I'm thinking man this is
way better than the Lord of the Rings in
Lord of the Rings they have to wait for
Gandalf man to be saved this was only
two and a heaven with them said that is
real life that happened in reality this
is more awesome than fiction
yeah you bring up a good point because
especially in the West were so
interested in media that we're living
our entire lives vicariously and now
you're not living like life i curious
you're living all these adventures that
God is sending you on you're
experiencing all the excitement for
yourself
amen you know and God can do it amazing
so instead of watching 300 you're having
Gideon's three holes they didn't hardly
have to do anything and the whole army
was defeated you know there's the
Spartans and really yeah really go after
and they did not have swords they were
given what torches and Bichir are they
gonna serve as waiters no they're going
to war they were given weapons that will
make them so helpless because it's
another lesson as our theme says the
Lord wants them to know absolute
reliance is the only way to win this
battle I got a chance to meet some of
these these friends of yours this summer
that when I was over there the
Philippines went with Jim and it was
neat they would sit down and they would
tell us the stories about you know their
first experience being exposed to our
ministry's material and how it had
revolutionised and then changed their
walk with God and yes and and once they
got rid of the clutter yeah you know our
audience sometimes always asks us you
know are you guys all you talk about is
Hollywood and you know just hammering
away at Hollywood because it's a real
real addiction it's a real prophetess
and when people have this like junk in
the mind
they can't appreciate the Simula City of
God and the Holy Spirit and working in
your life it's obvious so you know our
our ministry was really raised up clean
out the junk and you can really have a
powerful relationship with God and
that's the thing whether we like it or
not
it's just junk that's right we it stops
us from looking at reality and this is
reality God's Word is reality and and
when you look at it we are so
entertained to look at not the reality
of life yes we look at all the ugliness
of life but the main reality that God
wants us to see is hope it's joy
this peace this love the real love story
is this story and that's what happened
with us brothers got the moment we got
rid of the junk it's just like all the
blinders all the dark shades that
have been covering our eyes was taken
out and then really Candace
and it's funny because like every
Sabbath before every Church time we
don't we don't talk about church without
a watch this movie to come and I have a
DVD it's just waiting for the Sun to say
we'll run to my house and then binge
binge and then later on when we when we
watch this when we experience something
that's amazing I could not imagine 15
year old 17 year old after 30 plus years
old when we come together hey have you
read the patriarchs and prophets have
you read this chapter in in Genesis and
all those things and they light up
awesome and I even say man I could not
relate to my friends anymore right I
could not I could not share the things
that makes that makes me so joyful
I can't wait for church to come to share
all this and then they are happy as
young people I've been beautiful
you've seen them yes yes crazy happy
I've seen him I wanted you to show a
couple of pictures of some of these
prayer rooms for specifically what Jim's
ministry does he goes to different
conferences and he you know talks with
with kids about prayer and but but I
think what's really neat and what I got
to witness a few times being in your
prayer rooms was what was it five
o'clock in the morning five morning's
I've there was there were six hundred
plus kids in a room now this is a
conference that that happened tell us a
little bit of were seen here oh this is
a this is in GYC this is not in the
Philippines and just imagine in in the
US it's a challenge to gather people
together there on six it's like
equivalent of three a.m. in the
Philippines but you see when when the
Holy Spirit really moves when God's hand
is in it he takes care of everything
he's the one who pulls people in and
people are seeing now the joy of
spending
time in the presence of God yeah and
it's funny because we start at we start
at 6 they demanded can we start earlier
because we want to sing more you know
what what songs were saying we don't
even have a musical instrument we don't
have a praise team we we are there
kneeling together singing old hymns yeah
from with a thousand people I mean
literally I have you have you ever
experienced this to have have you
experienced this so to me surround sound
no there's nothing like not cappella
human voices yeah like singing hymns to
me that like I was just weeping like you
know everyone in the room you could just
hear snuffles throughout the whole room
because everybody is just emotionally
like like taking this in and it was just
a beautiful thing to see and there's one
one testimony that that was shared one
lady came to me after after GYC yeah and
then like couple of years ago said hey
Jim I have a story to tell you it's it's
awesome I brought this friend of mine
she's 70 years old 69 or 70 and since
she could not kneel down for a long time
so she pulled the chair near the door
and then while we were singing she held
her her friend held her said ah wait
I've experienced this once in my life
this is the second time and as my friend
her friend said what what is that I said
a year angels sing
a year in Joseon a gem the friend of
mine who told me that she's a music
professor hmm so she's not just making
things up and she was crying she said I
hear angels sing and then I realized
Scott like what people ask me brother
Jeff why is it different this sound is
different when we sing in church and we
sing in a prayer room and I was I was
somehow wrestling with that thought why
is it Lord and then I one time and I was
spending time in prayer and the Lord
somehow gave me this picture when we are
in church we are too distracted there's
a lot of things that's going around and
we're not even aware that we do not that
we come to the Lord and our hearts are
not ready to worship but when you are in
the prayer room remember when you go to
the prayer room
silent you are there you set your mind
to worship God and this is one thing I
realize it's not about the music that
will make that will make the worship
powerful it is important it is very
important it's not about the program but
it's mostly about God it is about the
spirit when your heart is ready to
worship the Lord could transform it and
just imagine we've been doing this for
years for how many years now
16 17 18 19 20 for five years now doing
this and we're doing the same format and
people keeps on coming in it's a this
that's the I think the whole point
through all of this is it is God through
and through hey Ben it's God that one
it's God the one that moves on our
hearts so that we even come to him and
then when we come to him in humility
were submitting to God like you said and
then on the other side it's God doing
the work of what we've asked according
to his will
there's a passage in Deuteronomy I think
illustrates this and it's talking about
Israel but I'd like to also apply to our
experience it says for your holy people
to the Lord your God the Lord your God
has chosen you to be a people for
himself a special treasure above all the
peoples on the face of the earth
the Lord did not set his love on you nor
choose you because you were more in
number than any other people for you
were the least of all peoples but
because the Lord loves you and because
he would keep the oath which he swore to
your father's and the Lord has brought
you out with a mighty hand and redeemed
you from the house of bondage from the
hand of Pharaoh king of Egypt and then
it goes on to talk about how God is
faithful he keeps his covenant in mercy
for a thousand generations for those
that love him and keep his Commandments
you know when you read this you see how
it's God through and through God doing
the working and it's nothing really to
do with us no and that's one thing I
think as well at the Lord one says two
wants to protect us from receiving the
glory because we are not really capable
of handling
glory will burners and and I remember
that as well that's that's one of that's
one of the pitfalls in the ministry
especially for for personalities like me
because we thrive in attention sanguine
the more you have lost the money the
sanguine dances and it is one thing I'm
thinking lower this is this is a losing
battle here because the more you bless
the ministry the more people will
appreciate so I I'm doing for failure
here you just have to grow in your
experience and is growing you yeah and
I'm thinking when you look at that
because the more the attention the more
the more your pride will grow the more
you want the glory and then the Lord
somehow somehow convicted me and because
when people appreciate you how do you
respond because it's easy to say like
praise the Lord but you want to take the
glory and then the Lord somehow taught
me give me the glory for real and then I
realized that every time we are
appreciated every time you receive that
glory is supposed to be God you have to
tell them know you have to know the
whole story I tell them and that is a
way to somehow brag about him
alright shift not a focus off of us to
him and you know it's awesome and as I
read in one of the passages as well that
the more we give him the glory the more
were you seen the joy so I'd rather have
the joy than the glory
I can handle glory so I'm talking of
going back to looking for God's answers
to our prayers God I know answers us in
three different ways it's yes no or wait
and then you have cases where maybe it's
all three like case where David is
praying to God about the sanctuary you
know I'd like to build you a sanctuary
God and he's like yes that's a good idea
no it's not you and just wait it's
coming with your son you know but I was
in a seminar once I'm talking about
prayer and how we should pray and a
story was given that
there was this man somewhere in some
place that hadn't rained for a while and
it was affecting the crops I mean the
prayer every day lord please send rain
please send rain and they were
connecting prayer with faith so every
day after the man said that prayer he
would leave for work with an umbrella
and expecting the rain hmm but I have a
question is there is there a line where
faith you can have faith but then it
crosses over into presumption mm-hmm in
looking for a specific answer to prayer
we actually cross over into being
presumptuous with our prayers
that's why submission is very important
submission is very important when you
come to him when you say your will be
done it's not your will you even
relinquish your desire you even
relinquish your preference and I believe
that if we come to the Lord with that
kind of mindset the Lord will even lead
us who need our thoughts the way he has
led Gideon the way he has led David in
all those things he will lead our mind
and he will somehow compel us keep on
praying and there is a very simple
what's this differentiation between
faith and presumption faith is obedience
presumption is disobedience you know you
guys brought up the story of Jonathan
and his armor-bearer it is interesting
when you go back and read that story
that yes Jonathan was bold and said
let's go and do this mmm but he wasn't
he wasn't saying I'm gonna do it anyway
he said let's let the Lord decide if
they say this then we will do this if
they don't say that we don't we walk
away and so it's important to be bold
for God but at the same time it's like
it's directed as bad and that's this is
a thing as well with most of the time we
are bold for God we want to do this and
we are not aware that we want to be in
the picture it's not fully his glory you
want this because you want your name to
be attached in the victory that God is
about to give it should that somehow
messes up the whole thing
when we come to the Lord we have to come
Lord strip me of anything
even even the answer would be contrary
to what I desire even it will cost me
this even it will cost me that that your
name be glorified that's the prayer that
God desires to answer and that's the
prayer that God wants us to be in
because by submission we will know his
will because in the end because in the
end even its weight no or yes if it's
his will is perfect mm it's always yes
yes
like this person Psalms 37:4 it says
delight yourself also in the Lord and he
shall give you the desires of your heart
once you align yourself with his will
God will provide things that you didn't
expect I know this is very real in my
own experience I used to work in in
agricultural chemistry in a laboratory
for several years and then behind a desk
doing an office job for a while yeah but
I've always been a person that I really
wanted to travel I really wanted to see
the world you know go different places
and experience different cultures and
food and people that's always been in my
heart I don't think that ever would have
been a reality in my life unless I would
have put my life in God's hands mm-hmm
and then when that happened when I when
I submitted to what God wanted me to do
and I said you know Lord if you want me
to be in ministry you're gonna have to
do this and this and this and God make
all these things happen it was at that
point where God led and then I was able
to start traveling and I've seen many
states I've seen different parts of the
world it's been it's amazing you know I
never would have had that opportunity I
don't think unless I would put myself in
God's hands I so God is amazing I'd like
to add to that because same story here
one of my favorite TV shows was a Travel
Magazine mm-hmm like a discovery so I I
see those people going from from place
to place every week but different
different groups of people learning the
culture and go into the beautiful place
and everything Lord I want to do that
and then I I realize it's so expensive
especially when living
especially when you're from the third
world rather Keith from the third world
going play just forget it
yeah and and of all the time that I was
working I've been a businessman since I
was six years old and and I realized
that for the past like 32 years during
the time in my life I was only able to
go to one country guess we're not
Indonesia your neighbor Malaysia on a
promo ticket and a twelve dollar and
then now that I'm a missionary the Lord
brings me to one place after another Wow
there was even one time that I was it
was my birthday and I was I was lifting
this this this prayer to God I arrived
actually late in California I arrived
like around 12:00 and at night before my
birthday and an early in the morning I
slept only like for three hours the Lord
woke me up and you know when the Lord
wakes you up it's not that you're you
want to go to the bathroom or a noise
wakes you up you just woke up and you
could not sleep right and at first I was
thinking oh man
like I need sleep but then you realize
the god of gods the king of kings wants
to talk with you so I became excited
yeah and then I I started I started on
my knees and before I could even finish
praying there's this song that came
count your blessings name them one by
one and then I started counting my
blessings that year alone I was able to
go to four different countries the next
one was a number of states that I
visited for the past like five months
that I was there here in the US
22 different states by the way better
Michelle I don't count states that I
just like lay over or pass through I
count states that I sleep on and and the
third one the third one was the number
of beds that I've slept on and you might
wonder why I began counting like that
because 2015 I was I was traveling for
four months and on that two weeks of
travel beginning of two weeks I was
already on my six bed it's just quite
amazing so I began taking selfies on my
bed
those on Facebook and named it my bed
blog I counted my bed for that year it
was 67 beds that's a lot of more than
one bed per week and then I realized Wow
Lord this is all your doing
yeah and then the last one the number of
airplane rides I had for that year
oh well 65 airplane rights oh I mean if
you just think of that like you know and
everything ticket is so expensive like
just to go three states over it's 500
oxy it out I mean I mean think of the
math do the math that's that's that's a
lot of money yes and God has provided
that whole way and that's that's amazing
when you talk about that a while ago it
really brought my mind into that like
thinking about the things that that you
were able to do without following the
will of God it's it's crumbs its crumbs
compared to cake or non-existent or
non-existent and and now see what God
can do it becomes so a lot of promises
that he says in the Bible officiants 3
verse 20 now unto Him who is able to do
exceeding it's not just exceeding it's
not just abundantly way above what you
could think or imagine we have not even
scratched the surface of what God can do
in our lives and that's the problem we
do not give him a chance because of that
we did not see the beauty of life we do
not see the power of life we don't see
the power of the God that we serve and
if you have a God as powerful as that
what stops you from absolutely relying
on him yeah I love 1st Thessalonians
chapter 5 verse 17 simple instructions
three words pray without ceasing
beautiful but Scottie you brought up
your kids you know we keep picking on
your kids coming up to you asking a lot
you know I'm hungry
you know I'm thirsty like it these are
serious needs but you know they may ask
it because they're impatient does that
apply to prayer like should we there's
different types of prayers you know we
start with praise but what if there's a
need in our life big or some
it's a need and we present it towards
God should we keep nagging him should we
keep everyday asking asking asking or
should we pray we know he's heard and we
just wait we just I take the Jacob
approach hold on to him every like sorry
not letting you go do this as answered I
just have had some big things in my life
I've learned to pray for little things
but I've also had some very big things
and you know sometimes that takes us
praying again and again and again and
again
and I I don't think it's because he
doesn't hear us and III think it really
just shows our earnest II I mean I think
the reason why you know fasting is a
great part of prayer is his listen I'm
willing to set aside any of mine my
needs and this is very important to me
and so I I personally would would pray
multiple times for something no I agree
and I think it is more for us than for
good I remember prayer is submission
yeah so when you come to him and even
that even that thing that he wants you
to to plead continually he will lead you
because there there is something for
example it's a salvation of one person
those are the things that that the Lord
it is the Lord's will that a person will
be saying as the Lord's will that that
person's heart will be changed those are
the things that we have to cling on to
yeah I will not let you go oh Lord until
you move my father's heart yeah I was in
a camp meeting in Washington once and
there was a baptism that happened to
camp-meeting and a little eight-year-old
couple that got up there she had been
praying for a husband for 50 years yes
Wow and and literally I don't think
there was a dry eye and we filled the
baptism let's just like because I mean
just the thought of that is amazing that
your wife's dedication of prayer to her
husband and then I got a chance to
witness this moment that was an answered
prayer and it was just like I mean there
was just nothing you could you could
even say it was beyond words yeah but it
was
beautiful George Mueller had the same
experience similar anyway five friends
and he prayed for those five friends
over a period of 50 years four of them
he got to see succumb to Christ the last
one after 50 years healer died and three
days later that last man he was hard to
love ya this we we are not really aware
or we don't really comprehend what
prayer can do if we pray the right way
mm-hmm again his will be done most of
most of the time our prayer is overly
what we want to happen not what he wants
to happen did we even come on her knees
and ask God what do you want me to pray
for today Lord because it's always what
we want and just imagine just imagine
friends like seeing God now his
perspective not our perspective now his
perspective now seeing you submit seeing
you made willing to be made willing
mm-hmm
just imagine God's God's eyes closed and
someone say now I could finally show
this person what I want to happen in his
life Wow Wow I heard a story recently
when I was in Brazil
mmm a pastor had gotten to Paris and he
was visiting just as a visiting pastor
he was from Brazil and so the local
pastor took him around of course to the
Eiffel Tower and he had been up in the
Eiffel Tower the pastor so many times
was he's taking guests there and so he
he said oh my son we'll take you up
there and you know like you guys can
take pictures and stuff like this and
I'll wait down here
three hours went by three hours and the
pastor was just like okay what happened
to them like they're up top they came
down the son was just like clearly like
you know kind of in shock and they all
got in the car nobody said anything and
as they started to drive away the pastor
was like should I ask like what happened
on the top of the Eiffel Tower yeah
didn't say anything and they pulled into
a little convenience store the
the visiting guy wanted to get something
from the convenience store so as he went
in then the father turned to his son and
said okay now's my chance what what
happened up there it seemed like you you
knew you're a little different he said
do you realize what this man did he went
on the top of the Eiffel Tower and for
three hours he prayed over the people of
Paris in every direction as loud as he
could at the top of his lungs Wow and
the pastor was just like wow this is my
home city hmm and I have never done that
well like you think about that I mean do
we pray for even that the towns that we
live in the people the churches there's
a there's a little school around here
that my kids attended to and they're
there there was a group of ladies that
would go around and pray in every
classroom they would pray over the
classrooms and they would spend hours
doing it in the morning every single
morning well so I have a question to
that should every person be interceding
is it the job of us are there some
criteria I can we intercede I think it
would be safe to say that that everybody
has a friend that is not connected to
God would you say that do you have a
family member a friend cousin relative
you name it right my best friend is is
you know one of the guys that I spent a
lot of time in in Los Angeles never came
to God and the last thing I did was was
tell him why I was leaving Los Angeles
and and you know I've been praying for
him for years that he would somehow come
to God so I hope that I have that
testimony someday that one of my really
close friends would would make a
decision an intercession intercession
somehow changes us it it takes away your
focus from ourselves towards other
people it somehow gives us a picture of
what the heart of Christ is so that's
that's one thing and I guess everyone
everyone is designed to be intercessors
mm-hmm and this is one thing that we
have experienced when we went to Iceland
to pray for the whole country and then
you might wonder like why do we have to
go to Iceland we could pray
in the US why spend money and effort and
organizing all those things and it's one
thing that I like to tell you well while
we were going around we were praying the
Lord do the impossible for Iceland so
this save this place the moment you go
around and see the people that you're
praying for there's this burden that the
Lord puts in your heart that was not
there before and I begin to even be
emotional to have that that that need
for this place to be reached by God and
this is one thing the Lord wants us to
to have that burden because we don't
care most of the time or intercessions
or intersessions i lord i just at the
back of my mind i just have to get it
done in over it so I could sleep but not
really give me iceland all right i mean
and this is one thing that it does to us
it takes away our selfishness it takes
away our focus upon ourselves and the
focus that we have on ourselves
brings us a lot of dissatisfaction he
brings us a lot of unhappiness
everything that the Lord requires us is
actually for a joy mmm that's one
amazing thing about the gut Reserve and
it sounds like it's important to be
specific
nah lord please save the world you know
no let's think about who exactly in your
life can you specifically pray for and
you know even even the things in our
lives
mmm if you just say Lord save me well
how about you think which areas of my
life should I be working on so that's
possible and pray specifically for that
and keep your attention there to see how
God works how he moves so you can later
thank him for how he's answered your
prayer and believe me when you submit
the Lord will bring it up mmm what to
pray for what to Pretoria he is specific
mmm he is a God of order he will make it
so specific for you he's also a God of
action amen and I believe he will lead
us to do certain actions in
circumstances so for example if you have
a friend who doesn't know Christ
yes started by praying with for them the
Holy Spirit will convict their heart I
think God will lead you to the point
where
there's some action involved you know
maybe they need to receive a Bible maybe
they need to receive a Bible study maybe
they need a little tract or something
and and it's just like you know a
Jonathan and his armor-bearer
they prayed and God was ready to do
something and he prepared them to go and
enter into the conflict you know there's
there's an action component many times
no I'm not gonna say like every time but
many times there's an action component
that can be done at the right time as
God leads you know I don't think God
wants to just sit back now okay you know
whatever yeah that's true Matthew 26
verse 41 for the one yeah watch and pray
that you may never enter into temptation
so yes pray but also watch um can we get
more specific what do you think rice is
meaning by my watch I think you know
like in James case I'll do it we'll pick
on Jim here I think Jim came to a point
where he was convicted about something
idea in his life he starts preparing
thought about it he can pray to God
about it and be convicted about it all
day long but intelligent em takes those
DVDs and takes that media and starts
removing it from his home in his life
it's probably not gonna result in the
change that God wants to work no
progress yeah no progress so there are
there are practical things that I think
God will lead us to reveal to us that
need to be done you know it's like you
know if you want to stop drinking all
don't keep going to the Lord yeah if you
want to stop smoking stop buying
cigarettes ya know and then I believe
God will give you the strength to stop
buying the cigarettes and he'll give you
the strength to overcome that addiction
and and not have it anymore but there's
that I guess there's that practical
component to that God will lead in as he
moves the Christian walk is repentance
and remission of sin it it it is a
desiring to take us from where we start
but not leave us there
and move us in a progressive manner
closer and closer to holiness mm-hmm so
yeah definitely action involved in that
amen and that's one thing that that that
I see I see everything from the joys
perspective from now on hmm because when
you look at that like repentance why
would the Lord want us to repent I mean
why would the Lord want it to be to be
gotten rid of sin because that blocks us
from his presence that blocks us from
having that intimate relationship with
him and some 16 verse 11 says that will
show me the path of life in his presence
is what fullness of joy at the right
hand there are pleasures forevermore and
when you think about less sure it's
always associated with worldly pleasure
isn't it yeah and we forgot that the
author pleasure is gone right and that's
the real pleasure that God is trying to
offer to us and for me the reason why
I'm doing this because I'm joy how can
you not be addicted to joy yeah and the
reason why I'm I'm having this
disposition is because being in his
presence is the most awesome thing
beingness in his presence it's what God
wants his people to be in because just
imagine if you tell people about God if
you're not happy with the garlic you
serve that's not gonna be a good
advertisement right like you want to use
this shampoo yes if you're not convinced
yourself and this is one thing that the
Lord wants us to experience because the
moment you try him
you could have keep it to yourself yeah
so I have a question um the devil has
free will I'm just like we have free
will and God although all-powerful
Almighty respects everyone's free will
God is the only being who can read our
minds and knows our hearts the devil
can't can't read our minds but he
listens and he observes our practices
yes exactly so my question is should we
pray silently
or out loud because the devil is always
listening yes you know and remember yes
God can shift things around and stop the
devil but then at certain points he must
respect not only our free will but his
as well as however twisted that sounds
so I'm just curious this is one thing
that I but I was faced with before
because one when one person was not so
approved of United prayer I said we have
to know that the devil is listening and
then this is one thing that I see
ourselves going to trap that we over
magnified the power of the devil okay
mm-hmm
but when we look at the Battle of Mount
Carmel remember that time that they were
praying that the fire will come down
good a devil make a fire no he could
know that it what God Allah
yeah he can create a fire he could he
could do fireworks and all but why in
that moment he can I didn't minam yeah
God found the enemy and just imagine
this if you are this loving God if you
are this this all faithful all powerful
God and you see your your child
sincerely desperately hanging on to you
calling upon your name would you allow
the devil to myself mm-hmm that is not a
picture of our God that is not so we
should not be afraid to pray cloud and
especially again going back to
submission if the if the Lord convicted
to pray long pray loud sing praises and
because this is the thing as well at I
that I that I realized when I am am
afraid
when I am troubled when I am in doubt
when I am attacked with all those
negativity start praising God start
thanking God go into that mood of like
okay Lord helped me to be reminded of
all those things and you know what the
devil does during the time he goes away
running there is a testimony that I
watched of a guy who is from a Satanist
family really part of like Satanism
where
would actually go into neighborhoods in
New York City and pray over the the the
the streets and stuff that the demons
would have power over them Wow and you
know what stalked him he actually would
do astral projection he would fly over
the top of the cities I mean you should
watch this guy's testimony it is amazing
and yeah he would go into these
neighborhoods and there was a couple of
times where there was preachers they
street preachers that would pull up the
back of their car they had a couple
speakers and he was not allowed to go
into those neighborhoods his his spirit
had no bearing whatsoever in those
neighborhoods just because there were
street preachers in the streets
literally preaching to God is his
testimony is powerful so yeah I would
agree
you know like God is powerful and you
know no matter how powerful the devil
thinks he is you know it's like God
doesn't want him to be around he's gonna
protect you and that's one thing I saw
in that in that picture like the comedy
of the Bible because just imagine all
all all Satan's hosts were trying to
light up the fire but every time they
play point it's like smoke it would not
happen because God would not allow them
and if you read the book was this
Patrick and prophets when when Elijah
was there standing that that was the
loudest appeal that was ever done
because no one came forward to be on the
Lord's side
he made this appeal to the Israelites
who long he wants to be in the Lord
sighs come stand for the Lord no one
stood with him and it says there Elisha
might have appeared to be alone but this
is the most amazing thing said above and
around him were angels of excelling
strength Wow
their angels were so many that they
could not fit on the ground that they
have to be on top of one another so
sometimes we're thinking that the enemy
is powerful but this is one thing when
we are on the Lord's side we are in the
most powerful side
they've been a man thank God well any
final thoughts you have on prayer did
actually I do have a question for you as
well and and maybe this will be for our
audience as well if they don't know
where to begin how to start where do you
start on your knees on your knees this
is one thing that as we have talked a
while ago God will take us as as we are
come to him and talk to him as a friend
like even talk to him at times that you
don't want to talk to him and this is
one amazing thing about our God you
cannot pretend in front of him so tell
him even when you're angry I didn't tell
him that you're angry at him just talk
to him he can handle it he can handle it
and build that communication with him
and do not stop he until you find him
because Jeremiah said seek me and you
will find me when you search for me with
all of your heart and I know that the
Lord will bring us from anger to
softness until we submit until we see we
see him the fullness of him and we be in
his presence that will find the fullness
of joy his right hand specials for
everyone and that's one thing I'd like
to encourage our viewers do not give up
on God do not let go and you do not see
him for the first five minutes for the
first time in sore even for the first
day or week cling his promise cling to
his promise seek min you will find me
because you will find him and he wants
he wants you to find him yes I know for
me even at one point I was still
intimidated to even speak my own words
to the Lord I just didn't know what to
say and someone encouraged me to speak
the Lord's words back to you and the
Bible is full of prayers there there are
people who have gone before has done
this before Psalms The Book of Psalms
plethora of prayers that you can not
only read and apply in your life but
also say back to the Lord and this is
also encouragement for for strong prayer
warrior
to go out and seek people to pray with
to encourage them to instruct them so so
so that they don't feel so alone and so
overwhelmed with just the concept of
prayer I have something on the - I
remember when I was a kid our parents
tell us just do the Lord's Prayer and
maybe by doing that it's gonna make us
used to come to the Lord and then
somehow we will know and the next time
what to say to him yes our little kids
start you know you start with the Lord's
Prayer yeah and doesn't have to be a
10-minute prayer you know how does a
little kid pray lord thank you for this
meal and it's so passionate you know so
genuine even that is enough and there's
one powerful coat that I remember forgot
the reference but it says it is the
Lord's will to indite his prayer in our
hearts and me not being an English
speaker I have to go back to the
dictionary what's the word any night and
die means to compose mmm just imagine
that even the prayers that we will be
praying is not actually like coming from
our intellect and just imagine this I'm
not an English speaker
I was not even comfortable speaking
sermons in English before I became a
missionary and that was almost 10 years
ago and the Lord is just putting words
in my mouth and God is amazing we serve
a powerful God that's right well we hope
you guys were blessed by today what do
you say we end this with a prayer and
what do you say we pray for our audience
if you guys have anything you need to
bring before God he is so easy to
approach and it's very simple and so we
just want to say a quick little prayer
over our audience anything you guys just
a general prayer but Jim we do the
honors let us pray you're gonna heaven
Lord we pray said we thank you because
you are a powerful God and you're the
God who's concerned even with the
littlest details of our lives
even know the numbers of our hair how
much more Lord are the things that we
are struggling with right now today
father I pray for each and every
audience that's watching this or hearing
this the lord I pray that before they
run to anyone else may they run to you
or please teach us Lord how to draw near
to you and and allow us to give you a
chance in our lives your father I pray
for a special anointing of your Holy
Spirit upon each one upon those who need
you the most we praise and we thank you
Lord that there is no limit of how near
we can draw to you a father please just
through your heart is what we ask the
loving name of your son Jesus thank you
for stopping by again today and if
you're new to this channel definitely
hit that subscribe button we've got a
lot of content that we're putting out
you know hit the notification bell
you'll get a notification when we put
out a new video and definitely check out
our work at little light Studios TV
especially if you have an interest in
the field of media you watch movies
television we've put out a lot of
content in that area and as well thank
you so much to our supporters and if you
would like to support this ministry you
can check out our patreon page and you
can support us that way thanks so much
for stopping by it we'll see you next
Friday
god bless
[Music]